[Music]
[Music]
hmm
he's always just like i can't even
sniffle in my own house
so
yeah like sniffled like normal yeah you
know what i mean so i'm not allowed to
breathe in my own house no no
you're on camera you can be sniffling
and [ __ ] i wasn't on camera sniffling
then the cat goes like
oh because the cat thinks you're hissing
at her
you know she does that every time you do
something every time you sneeze or every
time you like
every time i kind of scratch my legs
smoking the last herbal cigarette yeah
he's taking all my herbal cigarettes
yeah
more though this thing's meth all right
i thought
i think they're banning anything menthol
aren't they i didn't hear that yeah i
just
heard yeah esther
made it hi everyone taking care of a
sick parent so maybe off and on oh gosh
okay okay well i hope that works out for
you
yeah uh zach is saying i just watched a
very interesting doc about this guy i'm
gonna have to check this one out too
yeah i feel like this one
because i feel like we we watched a
documentary about um
son of sam david berkowitz not too long
ago i guess because we did a show about
him not too long ago
yeah and um so this one so i thought
when somebody recommended this one i
thought they were talking about that one
but no this is brand new
this just came out like last week on
netflix and this is so much
it is about david berkowitz but in
particular
it's about the theory that
he was that he didn't act alone that he
was part of a satanic cult yeah okay
which i think we got into a little bit
on the show um
when we did the show about him and i
appreciated that this
it's four episodes the episodes are
about an hour long or 48 minutes or
something like that
so i kind of appreciated that they went
into
that aspect of it even though i think
and i think i said this on this okay so
the documentary was a little bit more
convincing
than some of the [ __ ] that i read yeah
it sounds like there's something to this
theory
there's a lot of things that had
happened around
where berkowitz lived there was some
stuff that in the letters that he sent
and there were some people that believe
that he didn't act alone and there there
was some evidently like some occult
stuff happening in some woods around
where he lived
and then an investigator comes in tries
to put all this together and say that
the cops [ __ ] [ __ ] up that this
that he was just
one of many people that were involved in
this and they
as the as the series goes on they try to
make you kind of believe that i guess
now they really attract they try
now they just try to demonstrate the
theory i guess well yeah it's sort of
i you know the documentary doesn't
really take a stand on it one way or the
other because what it is
is um so the the journalists that came
up with this theory originally
and this was like back in the visit back
in this late 70s or early 80s like not
too long after the um
after the crimes had taken place in 1977
uh his name was maury terry
and what ended up happening was that he
worked on it for a really long time he
wrote a book called the ultimate evil
he was on all the talk shoes on geraldo
and all that [ __ ] back in the day
and what happened with that was that
when he died in 2015
he was friends with joshua zeeman
who he's a documentary filmmaker he also
made cropsy probably his best known one
which is actually a really good
documentary if you want to check it out
might be on to be actually that might be
where i saw it uh it might be on shutter
too i can't remember
um but he made that one and he and him
and maury terry were friends so when
maury terry died
he left all of his investigative notes
about the quote unquote sons of sam
theory
to joshua zeman so joshua's even made a
documentary about it
so it's almost kind of like it's it's i
like the way they set it up
because the first episode pretty much
gives you
a rundown of the son of sam crimes
you know which only to which took place
over a year um you know and all the
shootings and everything like that and
it also kind of goes into the cultural
context
how shitty and crime-ridden uh new york
city was at the time
and how um during this summer when this
was going on it was like [ __ ]
flipping out there was like you know
those blackouts there was all this other
kind of [ __ ]
they actually made a really good movie a
couple years back well a couple years
back many years back called summer of
sam
with john leguizamo where it's kind of
it's not really about david berkowitz
but it's kind of about that whole
chaotic
kind of summer like all it was just like
all this [ __ ] happening at once
so the first episode is that it's kind
of like goes over the crimes
goes over you know talks to the victims
families and all that
and then it just kind of gives you a
little tease
that some of the uh police sketches
of the uh perpetrator by survivors and
by
you know people that saw the [ __ ] happen
um
some of them didn't really look anything
like david berkowitz right so they one
of them kind of did so
yeah so they kind of tease that and then
as it goes on
they get more into maury terry as a
person like they talk to his you know
you know people that knew him they
talked to his ex-wife and um you know
and friends of his
and so it's almost as much about him
as it is about david berkowitz you know
what i'm saying like about his
obsession with the case and about his
years-long you know crusade
really to get the police to listen to
his satanic cult theory
right yeah i yeah he he was uh if you
ask me
he was obsessed for one reason or
another he was yeah
i don't know if it was just a show
business money type obsession
or maybe it was just something about him
in particular
he kind of went on a damn crusade now
this was during the time of what we what
chatty and i
called well yeah me and jane lived
through it it was called the satanic
panic
yeah okay it was some crazy [ __ ] you
think today's moral panics were bad
it was [ __ ] bad back then they
actually thought there was a nationwide
cult
of satanists they were breeding children
and sacrificing them
and that they had infiltrated the police
and the fbi
and that it they actually and
infiltrated rock music and [ __ ]
it was it was ridiculous and the dragons
the smurfs for christ's sake
yeah you had televangelists involved and
stuff
um well i was a big cash cow for them
yeah
and what's weird is that politicians got
involved in it this is the time where
the republican
party really got kind of the stigmatized
as being crazy ass bible thumpers
was deer in the [ __ ] satanic panic
and they were they were [ __ ] crazy as
bible thumpers not all of them
but a lot of them were and and for some
reason other republicans listen to them
and then they try to do things like
ban rock music and just crazy
overreactions and [ __ ]
um yeah it's a it's interesting because
uh i'm very excited because what one in
the in the uh
topic poll for friday night's show is
we're doing a
a revisit of the satanic panic from that
time period
so i'm super super excited because what
we did the satanic panic
on our second show episode two that was
like almost five years ago
and that show was only it was super fun
and i think we covered a lot of ground i
can't remember i haven't listened to it
a long time
but it was you know only an hour long or
something
so it's like i want to redo it and
you know expound on you know expand on
some stuff we talked about there so
you know and not have a time limit and i
so i thought it was really cool that we
ended up watching this documentary which
has a very satanic panic element to it
because it happened during that time
period
and i think that that's kind of one of
the traps maybe that maury terry fell
into
because the thing about it is that okay
i will give him that i would have got
suspicious too
if a bunch of the witness because they
do show like
all of the police sketches of you know
what they called them the 44 caliber
killer
and you know none of them really looked
like one another
honestly so i probably would have
thought that was kind of fishy too
um so you know there's something there's
something to investigate there
there is probably also something to
investigate behind
you know and i'm not saying david
berkowitz is innocent obviously because
they caught him he had the [ __ ] gun
in the car
it's like you know what i mean so there
was a lot of other evidence uh
implicating him clearly and so but some
of the weird [ __ ] that he said in the
letters
about you know quote-unquote john
wheaties and all this other kind of
stuff
um that's the thing you don't really
know
if he was referring to um
you know his neighbors sam carr yeah son
of sam
and the dog was telling him what to do
blah blah that was sam's dog
and sam had two sons john
wheat carr john which who they called
wheaties and
another one named michael and
the theory is that these two were
helping david berkowitz because uh you
know john and michael
uh carr did actually look like some of
the other sketches
so it could have been i mean it could
have been that they were lookouts or
that they were
have or something like that i just think
you know i'm not saying that that's true
i'm just saying that's possible
but when you get into this thing where
because it seemed like
maury terry kept going farther and
farther and farther with it until it was
you know suddenly it was a nationwide
satanic cult they're all
in with the process um you know which
was a real thing i know
um you know and now there's like you
know there's a murder out in california
that was arless perry which they thought
was related and then there were like
these couple other ones that were
related
so there's a lot of problems with this
theory yeah
all right i think the
the big give the one of the main things
against the theory
is that the crimes that were committed
by berkowitz could have
actually more easily be done by one
person than many people
yeah because to require a team first of
all
serial killer has been killing people
solo forever that's normally how they do
it yeah
and it's because they they're by
themselves there are no witnesses and
they choose when to strike
and sometimes sometimes couples but
that's much much rarer
yeah uh the whole idea of having an
organization behind you
and be able to keep that secret for a
long time period of time
history shows that no the more people
involved in it the [ __ ] less
the less your chances of you ever
keeping that [ __ ] secret
it's better if it's just one person
acting alone
and leaving no surviving witnesses
that's usually that's the best way
um and the the crimes that he committed
they could have they could have you know
their their obviously could have been
easily done by one person
they were things that didn't require
multiple people
you know yeah i mean he was basically
just walking up to cars and
shooting yeah people in cars and then
running away
well it was more complicated than that
yeah but it was walking around
waiting for a couple who was in a
position where there were no witnesses
where you could get a shot or two and
then run away unobserved
yeah okay you can walk around shoot
people in cars all day long but you'll
get caught
sure you have to he was waiting for the
[ __ ] [ __ ] perfect situation
he sees him looks around goes this is a
good place pow and then [ __ ] and then
runs
yeah and then as soon as he gets around
a quarter probably just walks because
running
[ __ ] attracts attention you know yeah
so
yeah this was just one dude and
it was it was just a byproduct of the
satanic panic thing
people reading into it too much oh well
[ __ ] this must be
this must have you know this is this is
a complicated crime
this is gonna require four or five
people now berkowitz himself comes out
and says yes i was in a
satanic uh cult and yes i wasn't alone
but he wouldn't give up any names
he's lying he's lying yeah that's what i
mean it's like he's a serial killer
so i don't know how much uh you know how
much stock you want to play
[ __ ] there are notorious liars all
right and
the purpose for the lie is is several
many fold right actually one you can
take
some of the blame and guilt off of you
and put it on
imaginary people yeah it wasn't just me
a bunch of people did it
so that all right and then all of us
then you can now claim
i'm part of an organization it's like a
satanic gang
yeah we're i have power well i have
power i'm part of this or
and you know in jail in prison [ __ ]
he can walk around like he's some kind
of gang member
now the chances of those other prisoners
believe in that is about zero
yeah those other guys in prison go yeah
right
sure yeah that [ __ ] yeah right whatever
you've heard they didn't yeah because
they they lie you know they know they
they're telling prison stories
and and the good thing about the
documentary is that
cops cops threw their two cents into it
and they say
jailhouse information is notoriously bad
because they lie yeah because they have
their own agendas
yeah and also you know they get pulled
out of the [ __ ]
normal population to have a nice day in
the vineyard
visitor center and talk to people and
tell
stories and you know they feel important
because
people from the outside won't talk to
them going to give them some cigarettes
maybe buy them a [ __ ] soda or some
donuts
it's just some [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean and then they didn't have to
go on work detail that day
some you know it's gonna be real basic
[ __ ] like that
and then they can go back to into the
cell
block area and go oh yeah they're
talking to me they're going to make a
whole movie about me yeah i'm just
telling everybody
everybody else how famous he is you know
so no you can't believe that
that's what i mean and so that's the
thing it's kind of like
as i said yes it's weird that
the [ __ ] that he said in his letters
about wheaties and everything like that
yes that those did seem to be real
people
he knew
he might have hung out with them he
might have you know what i mean and he
might have just put that in there be
weird i don't know
he was doing something like the zodiac
would do yes giving them hints
about how to catch him yeah you would
have to know him exactly to understand
those
right you know yeah because he's
referring to people that live that live
next next door or like you down the
street or whatever
mixing their names up like the ant like
like just like uh
zodiac sending a damn yeah he's trying
to like oh
serious mysterious code that's what he's
talking about
and um berkowitz was not an impressive
guy
you know he was he was a doughboy you
know
loser in his youth prison actually
toughened him up a little bit he started
kind of getting a little bit better
shape
he looked like that guy roy schreiber
that [ __ ] no not roy charber
look like the guy from [ __ ] uh from
from what's that
actor from first a close encounter is
the third kind
the guy who was making a mountain in his
living room he looked like that guy
what was that guy's name got a little
richard dreyfuss richard dreyfuss yeah
he started to look a little bit like
richard dreyfuss but
slightly you know what i thought about
when yeah in his in
when he was in good shape and he got in
good shape for a little bit but he
looked like richard dreyfuss to me
and uh but he was a loser you know he's
gonna lie a pathological liar
he's a man of basically no achievements
you know and of no talent really just
had fantasies about
the devil you know he was kind of a
ramirez kind of guy kind of like a
richard ramirez type dude
not as scummy though ramirez was really
bad
yeah i mean he was just like a total
yeah ramirez really
was a bum you know he was he was on his
way to bum hood
you know had he not been caught he's
just been a bum yeah yeah
but yeah so that's the thing so you know
he could have just been like you said
being mysterious and writing this stuff
about his neighbors who are
may or may not have been friends of his
you know just to
kind of give police hints and make it a
little game or whatever
and he could be doing that and it's like
they didn't really have anything to do
with it
it is weird that wheaties ended up
uh dead over in minot north dakota
um in what they don't know was a suicide
or could have been a murder
uh they're not really sure about that
michael the other son
of sam uh also ended up dead
in a one car i think it was just a one
car accident that they said it looked
like somebody would run him off the road
although
i don't know how you know accurate that
is it could have just be a coincidence
and i just i don't know i feel like yes
that's weird yes that should have been
investigated and according to like all
the cops they interviewed some of the
cops like did actually think that maybe
you know yeah maybe he didn't act alone
but one the fact that the shooting
stopped after he got arrested
and i don't know i just feel like
yeah i feel like people are too and
particularly during this time period and
we'll go into it more on friday's show
because like i said we're doing another
show about satanic panic and i'm very
very jazzed about it because that's one
of my favorite topics
but i feel like people are just too
ready to
put too much meaning into stuff so i
think that he took a few tendrils which
could have been really interesting
you know why did the police sketches why
do they why did none of them look like
him
you know what is all this stuff that
he's putting in his letters mean you
know yes they match up with real people
that is absolutely something that should
have been looked into
but i think that past that he was just
looking for connections and finding
connections that maybe weren't there or
there was just like a stretch you know
what i mean
he was looking berkowitz wasn't the kind
of guy that would have been
attractive to a gang or or a cult or
anything i don't think
he was not a real social guy he he was
he was the loner type he didn't have
you know
he wasn't very he didn't have a lot of
social skills you know what i'm talking
about
yeah he was acting alone i you know i
kind of feel like that too you can just
look at him and see interviews with him
and
he's not the kind of guy that would have
a bunch of friends you know what i mean
and it nah i mean like i said yeah it's
weird that the police sketches
none of them look like him except maybe
one sort of but
you have to think too that eyewitness
accounts are notoriously unreliable
yeah um people might have been
describing
yeah so like i said they were under
stress they were like people might have
been describing someone else that they
saw in the area that wasn't actually the
shooter
lighting conditions were bad too i mean
i don't see how
how they could really identify them it
was dark and a lot of them that are a
lot of them were shot
yeah trying to trying to describe what
it was like or
witnesses in the area that around where
the shooting was
it's just now eyewitness testimony is
[ __ ] weak when it comes to id and
somebody
yes and i mean it's it's good to have as
like backup for other than like other
evidence that you have but if that's all
the evidence that you have then that's
really not it mostly helps when the
witness knows the person
yeah you go yeah it was tom it was time
that yeah
that kind of [ __ ] because you already
what did you do because you don't have
to id
him you already know the person yeah
that's usually the that's pretty good
witness id
yeah because honestly if i was watching
strangers you never remember how you
look yeah if i was walking down the
street and [ __ ]
well [ __ ] man people i pass on the path
every day yeah
yeah and if they were doing something
and somebody like
asked me to identify it i'd be like uh
he
had arms i don't know i don't ever look
at him that close
this was just part of the satanic panic
that's just the way yeah like i said
same mentality i can understand how
maury terry got so obsessed with it and
how
it's kind of one of those things that it
had like all these interesting little
anomalies that may have added up to
something
yeah but it just seemed like he got so
uh wrapped up in the narrative that he
was creating about this satanic cult
that pretty much anything that came up
he was
putting it into that narrative when
maybe it didn't have anything to do with
anything
because you know there was the whole
thing about arles perry that had that
uh that thing that happened in
california which i think i actually
wrote about
that was the woman she got murdered in a
church and like the
the killer like stuck a candle like
upper vagina and all this other kind of
stuff like it was almost like
ritualistic
but then they found out later and they
have like at the very very end of this
documentary
just a couple years back i think it was
2018 2019 2019
they actually finally got the dna
through and that it was the dude that
they thought that it was
uh all along like the security guard at
the church
had done it um who they thought it was
at the time but they didn't have enough
evidence
but um you know they finally did it is
he dead he killed himself
they said that's what they showed that
uh that news footage there at the end
that footage there
when they found out when yeah because
they went in the door they said we're
coming in you know we want to talk to
you about something
and it had been you know when did that
happen [ __ ] 1978 1939 or something
like that [ __ ] took himself and he
just
yeah he's just shot himself in that he
didn't want to go to jail no
so he knew he was busted i guess he knew
it was only a matter of time before they
figured out that dna
but see the thing about it is that it's
almost kind of like they put that at the
end of the documentary
to say well maury terry was right about
that because he did say
i think it's the security guard but he
thought the security guard
was in the cult yeah and because there
was this whole
thing too about a few of the um
like he was he his theory was that
wheaties
and michael carr were killed
um you know by the cult for whatever
reason and then there was like another
thing about one of them i think it was
maybe
was it michael or was it another dude
that was supposedly making snuff films
of the of the uh 44 caliber
killings like there was a van and they
like filmed the
and then the cult was like going after
the people that had made this enough
films yeah but that was no evidence of
that though
yeah and so it just seems like he took
the the kernel of something
which could have been something and then
just grew this
tree of connections together connections
that maybe i don't think were
necessarily
connections but i see that happens a lot
with like people that
with this kind of conspiratorial mindset
it's like you can take some kind of [ __ ]
like that but then you it expands out to
this
point where it's just like ludicrous and
it's just like all these people are not
involved okay it's just it's just
so so unlikely yeah it was just a it was
just the satanic panic mindset they
thought there was a whole
basically a whole like underground
network almost kind of like a mafia
of sadness it no
no it wasn't happening but they they
thought so though
yeah and the people actually went to
prison over this [ __ ]
they did like i said we're going to talk
about that we're going to talk about
mcmartin
we're going to talk about all that it
was it was a moral panic
and what was weird is that most of the
people that believed in
in in the satanic panic and in the in in
the satanic underground
never stopped believing in it
they what happened to them is that they
died
you know i mean they were baby boomers
or older a lot yeah
they died off most of them um you know
because during the satanic panic these
were people in their 40s or 50s back
then
yeah they're all dead now but um
then that that kind of belief in that
meant
belief in that thing went on forever in
those peoples it just
the media stopped paying attention to it
i think eventually geraldo
ran and the daytime talk shows hosts ran
it into the ground for so long it became
part of the jerry springer
scene yeah so they were like ah
let's let's move on to something else
and the average person who was young
like us
we didn't believe in that [ __ ] when it
was going over like no way
they had me going for a few years i was
thinking well maybe
but the bigger and the bigger that story
got the the more i was going no
and then when they started talking about
heavy metal music i was going no i was
like no they're misunderstanding they're
that is not what that lyric says or you
know or that band sucks anyway what are
you talking about
they wrote that to piss you off they're
pretending to be satanists those aren't
satanists
yeah you know and and to me i just
thought all that [ __ ] was funny that
adults believed it
i thought that was very but adults were
gullible
i mean it's funny until your ass gets
sent to prison
yeah because some idiot believed that
you were sacrificing babies
yeah it was a lot like the salem witch
trials where you had little girls
[ __ ] pretending that
ghosts were in them and demons were in
them and they would [ __ ] accuse
adults of [ __ ] and they'd [ __ ] kill
that adult
you could get a religious you could get
religious adults or you could get
you can get adults to believe anything
it doesn't even matter if they're
religious
you just have to feed their fears
whatever they're afraid of you go with
that
that's how you do it yeah you know but
the
i mean talking about like the the
daytime talk shows and [ __ ] like that
like i said i think that's how maury
mori terry and the whole um you know
satanic cult
david berkowitz thing really kind of got
into the media like the zeitgeist or
whatever because
he his book the ultimate evil um
you know when that came out that was
kind of like a big deal and he was on
all the shows they showed clips of it
like in the documentary which is cool
they had like it's all when he was on
geraldo and he was
on well there was no inside edition and
all that there was no social media the
closest thing to social media were those
damn daytime talk shows yeah
so it appeared there but it also
eventually died there
think about it yeah because they went
with that [ __ ] for [ __ ] years and it
just got more
well people kept watching it yeah well
it got more and more ridiculous as it
went
i mean everybody wants to watch some
[ __ ] about a satanic cult yeah cool i'm
gonna tune in for that that sounds
exciting
they were exciting i know but a lot of
times though if you watch the later
versions of the satanic cult things
the more questions you ask to the guests
the more hokey the answers and then the
audience would start booing them yeah it
was like something about a that medieval
era
it was yeah i mean or yeah it just got
like
what happened
so it's like the arena it was funny
and then jerry springer said [ __ ] it
let's break some titties out here
did that they had white trailer trailer
trash checks [ __ ] taking their
clothes off and fighting each other over
just
anything you know trailer trash fighting
each other and then people going yeah it
was like something out of the medieval
era
yeah yeah doing all those paternity
today yeah yeah yeah that's not your
baby
yeah and then [ __ ] some of this [ __ ] was
just [ __ ]
obviously fake yeah just obviously
obviously fake
white white woman white dude
black baby dude wants a paternity test i
don't think this baby is mine
it's obviously set up obviously yeah you
know well a lot of them were like actors
yeah yeah the crowd laughing and [ __ ]
you know just
funny i mean i'd even heard about some
some actors that kind of got their start
doing doing that [ __ ]
you would just like turn up and they're
like hey can you be this trashy [ __ ]
that
that's uh you know like you know this is
my baby daddy it's not my baby daddy
well jacob jacob we got a friend of ours
named jacob angel
and he's from colombia and he looks like
the devil
literally yeah all right he married a
friend of ours he's a real nice dude
real nice dude look at him you [ __ ]
go like what the [ __ ]
yeah he's scared and he would he made
his beginning
um on basically that's daytime talk show
hos in colombia yeah all right
and he's he's a performance artist he's
tall
he's kind of a skinny bald-headed guy
that looks like the devil
and um covered in tattoos lots and lots
of [ __ ] piercings and he has these
fantastic outfits
with the giant wings and and you know
implants in his head so he can put like
spiders and horns
yeah he's got horns and all this kind of
stuff just looking on jacob angel he's
on my friend's list
and um what's funny is that the dude was
a [ __ ] uh colombian army sniper he's
not
he he he was he's a [ __ ] good soldier
and [ __ ]
but uh you would think that he was just
some
[ __ ] like uh crazy ass [ __ ] fetish
dude or something i guess
in a way he was yeah but he was like
very conservative politically and
[ __ ] was into like civilization and
liked religions and
you know he was real proud of certain
aspects of catholicism and everything
but
you look at him you think he was a
satanist but he wasn't
nothing like that and he was real
disciplined he had some
issues with him but you know it was
nothing real serious
just he had a hard time fitting into the
united states he went back to columbia
but yeah he he went he was on a lot of
uh daytime talks
yeah whenever they needed somebody that
looked like a freak that everybody could
yeah you know cast dispersion yeah oh my
god
yeah oh my god and it was always some
fake [ __ ] like my daughter
married the devil and he had to like
pretend
to be some chick's wife you know i mean
or some girl's wife and
he was a bird yeah it was all just an
act well a lot of jerry springer [ __ ]
was just
well yeah because you couldn't get they
couldn't get guests to come on
yeah so you know you had to i mean
because the thing about it is that if
that was real
like if you really had some of the
problems that these people like why
would you go on national television
most people wouldn't yeah so i just kind
of feel like they you know
they'd give you like 200 bucks for a day
or something like that yeah and you
would just come in there and they'd be
like all right well you guys are brother
and sister and you're sleeping together
and you're totally proud of it
yeah so get out there and be like
[ __ ]
yeah do that so crazy ass shows like on
[ __ ] what's the name sally jessie
rafael and [ __ ]
one of what i'm gonna remember was like
i wanna marry my daughter
that was [ __ ] one of them yeah they
got what you know that shit's fake
well yeah yeah but like they don't care
if it's fake as long as they can
watch it [ __ ] stupid i mean the thing
about it and i think that that's kind of
why
the um like why maury terry's thing uh
kind of blew up so much was because like
i said everybody loves
true crime right everybody loves serial
killer not in that way but i mean they
they like to read about serial killers
they're fascinating i do too so i'm not
[ __ ] on people
and um you know what i mean but and if
that serial killer says yeah i'm a
satanist and i'm in with this cult and
there's all this
cabal of people that are going around
murdering people i mean peace yeah i
want to read about that
you know what i mean everybody wants to
read about that there's somebody in
there called toms and glorious bastards
and that's probably khan khan of oslo
junior is that you junior that's you
junior
yeah yeah tom's in glorious bathrooms
that's pretty funny
esther said i was wondering when tom
would bring up boobs right it's like
he can't go a single show yeah without
bringing up boobs
yeah i thought he could do it this time
because there were no boobs
no i brought up boobs i know you did but
you know i was gonna say but this uh
documentary this documentary didn't have
any boobs in it i don't think
it was low on the booboology scale it
was very low on the mobility scale
buddhism wasn't happening it was high on
the scary murder scale
yeah um and high on the satanic panic
scale
wasn't sexy not at all
but it wasn't meant to be no i mean it's
a good documentary though
i mean even if you don't because like i
said even if you don't i don't think the
documentary really takes a stand one way
or the other
um as to whether maury terry was correct
about the theory i suspect not
but um it just kind of examines
it you know the path that he took to get
to where he got to like with his theory
and
um and it also kind of talks a little
bit about maury terry as he as i said he
passed away in 2015
partly probably because of the [ __ ]
stress and [ __ ] like that because he
just got so obsessed with this case
and following up all these leads and
following up this cult [ __ ] and trying
to get the investigation reopened and
you know failing and all this other kind
of stuff and it's just he started
drinking and he lost all this weight he
lost his
you know his wife left and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and then he just
ended up like
dying of whatever like exhaustion and he
just looked like hell at the end they
said
yeah i don't believe that this had
anything to do with any kind of cults
i don't know this is going to work on
one man [ __ ] berkowitz was obviously
a very frustrated loner in cell
type guy he wouldn't have been good at
any kind of
gang or anything anyway um it's just not
not
he wasn't at that level during the time
that he did this yeah he came out
he was in the army but he wasn't anybody
important in the army he was
a worker bee and he wasn't there very
long he just was an incel
yeah he's an incel and you know like he
said it really seemed like with all the
letters and [ __ ] that he sent because he
did
you know like i said zodiac [ __ ] yeah
like he
he knew all the names of the
investigators he knew all the names of
the journalists that were working on the
case and he
you know wrote letters to them
specifically for that reason you know
what i mean he was trying to be
mysterious he was trying to be famous he
wanted the publicity
and i think that's pretty much the only
reason he did it he didn't really seem
to get
i mean they did they showed like some
snippets of interviews with him
what you know one that maury terry did
later on and then there were some of him
like earlier
and they were asking him um you know if
he got any kind of like sexual thrill
out of it and he's like no not really
but it almost seems like this doesn't
even seem like a sexual crime it just
seemed like he was
wanted to be yeah it wasn't a sexual
crime
you know in he did this [ __ ]
because of sex though if you ask me yeah
probably he was sexually inadequate
so you can't impress girls you sure
can't kill him though
he was kind of like lashing out he was i
think he was angry
probably not real aware of it i don't
think he was real emotionally
sophisticated you know what i mean
you're doing the dude who's
yeah he didn't seem to have a lot of
insight no no no you don't want to do
that probably like it you know
emotionally is like a [ __ ] eight or
nine year old you know
just he's not real well developed and
it's interesting that
the psychiatrist that they had before
they even caught him yeah and they had a
psychiatrist on there like at the time
like in the 70s
and he said pretty much the same thing
he said this is like someone who's
sexually inadequate yes this is probably
a virgin
he's probably virgins he might have been
yeah yeah because no women were ever
mentioned
and he didn't look like the kind of guy
that would uh was
he didn't look like a guy who who um you
know could get a date really
i mean there's nothing really physically
wrong with him it's just that he showed
the symptoms in his
behavior that he was a guy who was not
good with women yeah you know you you
know a guy could size up another dude
and go man [ __ ] if i was a girl i
want nothing to do with that dude
yeah we're not stupid yeah you know so
he just kind of came across that way
yeah he definitely did so
women are going for that especially
young women of breeding age
you know eighty percent of them eighty
percent of them or ninety percent of
them are going for the [ __ ] top three
percent of the guys
you know do they get the top three
percent of guys no
but they don't go very low on the
[ __ ] they don't go too
far down in the barrel most guys are
lose out
of the [ __ ] dating game i've seen all
the damn statistics
most guys lose they're kind of weeded
out genetically
ask japan most when most women in japan
find most of them in there unsuitable
they're kind of weeded out so the
population starts
you know shrinking the women have a
certain amount of standards
have a certain standard and most of the
men from that society don't meet that
standard so they don't
they don't get a girl they don't get a
girlfriend yeah it's just
it's like that in nature though too kind
of
true yeah cam guy said i'm gonna watch
this since we have netflix yeah it's
actually really good
i watched a couple different reviews of
it um most people like really liked
it one guy i saw really didn't like it
because he was just like it just
he thought it went off in too many
tangents and that and that it
uh could have been shorter like it would
have been a lot better if it was like
half the length i was gonna say that
because it is kind of four hours
now and like i said if you're expecting
the whole thing because i think he was
expecting the whole thing to be about
david berkowitz
um i wasn't expecting that because i had
heard like the satanic cult theory so i
wanted to go so
just keep that in mind just the first
one is kind of about the crimes about
david berkowitz
and then it's mostly about maury terry
and
his investigation into this satanic cult
theory that he has
so he's following up all the leads and
all that other [ __ ] so that's how the
rest of it goes
you know i mean the the last three um i
was thinking the same thing
yeah i could have done i could have told
this story it had been good in about two
episodes
maybe three yeah i didn't mind it being
four hours but um it's trying to
entertain you but yeah
i mean because i think i guess like
netflix their docu-series they tend to
be
four episodes that's how they do them is
berkowitz an organized or disorganized
killer probably organized
yeah he didn't get caught for a while
yeah it didn't seem like
didn't seem like it was just somebody
made him mad so he killed him
he went out hunting and he and he yeah
he shot him when the
when the time was right he probably
spent most of his time walking around
yeah and he really only got caught
because of like a parking ticket
yeah to be honest with you so if it
hadn't been for that parking ticket he
might not have been caught for i mean he
would have been caught eventually
obviously
yeah but um he might have gone on you
know for longer
so it just kind of happened that he got
that parking ticket and somebody thought
to like cross-reference it
and then not much planning or
fetishizing like with bundy
well you know it depends on what you
call planning okay
i think he used decent tactics which is
you you haunt certain areas where
there's a way in and a way out without
being seen
and you wait till the time is right so
is that planning
yeah that's plenty and he deliberately
went to different
areas knowing where they would be and
where you had a good place
so he didn't like hit the same place
like he would go to different boroughs
like he did some of the bronx he did
some in queens
you know what i mean a disorganized
killer is when dude's going into the
store to get a pack of cigarettes if
somebody said something [ __ ] sideways
to me blows that person's head off and
then [ __ ] goes after the cashier
and takes him out because he was a
witness and he goes oh [ __ ] i killed two
people
and then he goes through the damn cash
register and gets the money i need to
get out of here
and then he [ __ ] gets back in his car
and leaves all right leaving
fingerprints [ __ ] everywhere
yeah that's a disorganized killer sure
because he didn't [ __ ] go in there
with gloves to begin with because he
didn't plan
on [ __ ] robbing the store or killing
any of those people
it's because somebody said something to
him yeah and he [ __ ] goes off
yeah yeah all right so it looks like my
[ __ ] is crashing
again yeah but at least we got 45
whenever i say some hardcore [ __ ] they
got to crash it
see yeah they don't like me talking
about busting nothing up or
hurt anything or talking about [ __ ]
any of these like
cia or anything then they're going to
come after me yeah they're listening to
me no they're not
it's it's it's the algorithm okay
all right so i'm gonna go ahead and uh
shut this down because it looks like
it's gonna crash on me any minute
so thanks everybody for dropping by like
i said this is on netflix and it just
dropped a couple days ago so go check it
out if it sounds interesting
and uh we'll be back tomorrow probably
do a food show tomorrow
because we didn't do one last week so
we're kind of behind so
we will see you guys tomorrow thanks for
coming by have a good rest of your day
bye